hello everyone and welcome to a special
episode of generation next or console
crew whatever you want to be calling it
uh because it is the first anniversary
of the release of the playstation 5. so
to talk about the console's first year i
am joined by xbox expert jordan romain
yo
and playstation pro to hussein
absolutely
throbbing to talk about you've used that
one before playstation
he's hoping people have forgotten
gushing to talk about
sweating to talk about
that's fine it just sounds like you've
got some kind of i'm pitching a tent
here lads
no you use that literally last week
so we've all had consoles for about a
year now um which version of the
playstation 5 does everyone have i have
the disc one
tam yeah i've got the disc one and
jordan disc yeah so all disks do you
find yourself actually using disks i
have the genuinely the only desk i've
ever put into my playstation 5 is the
lord of the rings uhd 4k edition yeah i
have i i have a copy of demolition man
up in there let me tell you that
it's all up in them guts
i say no because i have the series x so
when i'm watching stuff i usually am
putting
discs into that i don't think i've yeah
i've never i don't even know if the disk
drive works i could have one of the
broken versions for the distributors
we'll never know
um how has it changed gaming for you
because obviously it had all of these
just like the xbox had all these big
shiny new features like
uh increased load speed graphics um
quality of life updates things like 3d
audio
what has been the standout thing that
you've noticed throughout a year of use
on on the ps5 i think i think like the
the main thing for me is something that
we'll come to eventually is
it feels like a
less um
kind of
an experience that has less friction
points than the ps4 i don't think the
ps4 had a lot
but i think there's there's some smart
changes that have happened for the
playstation 5 that i've made
jumping in and out much quicker and much
easier i still don't think it's it's
perfect there are various uh kind of
points that i get caught up on when i'm
playing games and and there's things
that i wish i had
many of which only i'm aware of because
they're on other consoles or they're
things that i the issues that i run up
into but overall i find it to be quite a
easy experience in kind of like jumping
in getting into a game playing for a
while jumping out um and i think the
main thing that defines the playstation
5 is it's got games it's got like unique
games that you can't ignore um and
that's like the biggest strength of that
of that um
platform without a doubt um
is is the main draw to it well so we'll
talk about games very shortly because
obviously there it's been a hell of a
year but
i i mean
jordan have done about you but i think
the load times and obviously on the
series x2 low times are fantastic and
it's genuinely stopping me doom scroll
but i think the thing that i wasn't
expecting to love as much as i do
has been 3d audio which is kind of
especially especially when you're
playing a game that really takes
advantage of it things like fraternal
astro um it's just been it's been
genuinely like amazing some of the audio
work and it kind of it's kind of audio
seems to be the much maligned you know
no one ever really thinks about it
unless it's really really bad and it
just feels like on ps5 it's kind of been
more of a standout addition for me
because like like i said graphics are
always going to get better load time's
always going to get better but stuff
like audio really stands out jordan
what's been your kind of favorite thing
i think i'm just going to pretty much
just echo you lucy like the audio has
really stood out to me the 3d audio
especially and just how the dual sense
controller itself utilizes audio like a
bit better and incorporates it like
just as a quick example like death loop
every time juliana like cuts in and she
uses the dual sense microphone to talk
to you as opposed to like your tv
speakers it feels more like an intrusion
on my life whenever it happens i'm like
oh this is a very nice way of making me
feel
more akin to what colt is feeling where
it's like oh there's this voice that
keeps jumping in and i
it frightens me and anners me every time
that she does um and so they've just
used audio in really cool ways and the
way that they sometimes tie that audio
to
the different haptic feedback and things
going on with the dual sense and the
vibration and everything it's just
awesome it doesn't always work i don't
use it whenever i'm playing a shooter on
a
playstation 5 but like for the most part
like all the new features that they've
added with this new generation have just
been
wonderful
i i think it's the first gimmick the
dual sense being
is the first gimmick based controller
that sony have successfully pulled off
like not gimmick in in their traditional
sense where it's like like they tried
with a six axis that was hot trash then
they went back to like
just the standard dual sense stuff did
the dual shock stuff which was way
better and this the features on there
are kind of a gimmick by definition like
the speaker and and like the always
listening and always recording that kind
of thing
and the haptic feedback or whatever is
called in this
but it actually works and it's not
intrusive and it's not something and
it's funny because they didn't make a
big deal out of it um they just kind of
put it in there and they were like yeah
it's got this stuff and it works um it
wasn't like the the six access the
motion stuff they were like we are all
about this
um and and i think i really appreciate
it because of that way more um
the speaker and the uh and the
microphone just being on the controller
has been massive it's been genuinely
helpful for us in a few situations where
we were without um you know headsets
because we were moving around and having
that as a clutch uh replacement was
really good yeah has backfired on a
number of games oh yeah well like
remember destruction all-stars when like
people could hear other people trash
talking like at all times and there was
no way to turn it off at the start and
it records you when you're getting a
trophy because i know andy cortez uh did
a great one on he was doing run on demon
souls and it's just him kind of
screaming around because he gets the
trophy yeah i i it records you it's
always recording you unless you mute it
so like i have multiple mass effect
moments that i've had not been able to
post because
uh like you know halfway through a funny
moment i've accidentally i've not farted
in a room and you're like you can hear
that
i mean
you gotta say i gotta hope it's not [ __ ]
but um you could say vaped but i'm glad
i'm glad you went for that i'm telling
you the truth i'm trying to tell not
like it is now my experience with the
dual sense um i i really enjoy it i
think like i said in games where it's
fully fully optimized um when there's
like little little
pitter patter of rain and stuff it's
very very nice however i will say that
i've i've turned the vibration and the
controllers down because this is just me
but i have really bad repetitive strain
injury in my wrists and so
for an extended extended use um
sometimes it can just be a little bit
overwhelming so i have turned it down
and in shooters
yeah it's just not
i don't want to meet resistance like in
in death loop obviously it's kind of a
mechanic you if you have like this janky
gun it can
jam and stuff but then i was like
well i just i just
i'm gonna turn that off but the the mic
in the in the dual sensor is really cool
uh a feature one of my favorite features
in the ps5 that not many people seem to
know about or use it's an accessibility
feature
and it's fantastic that it's there but
it needs a lot of work which is the text
to speech
the speech to text sorry so you can turn
on
in your party chat you can turn on
uh speech to text
and it's like talking to siri or
something some of it they're gobbled
stuff i mean one of one of those was my
favorite which was um big uncles big
nightmare like just absolutely random
stuff but i will say there's other cool
things like
you know a friend of ours simon was
playing bloodborne for the first time
and we were in a party and he was
sharing his gameplay and i could just
pin it i can pip it so it could just be
like in a small corner i didn't have to
watch the whole thing so i was playing
mass effect or something at the same
time and i could just be talking to him
watching him play and then if it was a
pivotal moment i could just increase the
size of his screen and so that's really
really cool i think what they'd be doing
with parties because originally
the original layout was pretty bad we're
this close to getting snapback
and
just take that functionality and put it
on netflix or youtube and it would be a
game changer literally speaking for
people who just
like us who need to be doing 700
different things at the same time yeah i
would love to be able to watch a youtube
video while grinding it out on on some
rpg yeah i mean i really really hope so
um so the other thing that they massive
sony's massively changed over the last
year is
storage so it was always more
straightforward to increase storage it
seemed on xbox obviously they had the
little expansion cards with playstation
it was a little bit funnier you could
put ps5 games on your
oh no you couldn't but was it you
couldn't put ps5 games on the external
storage first and then you could
but you can't play them off external
storage and so if you want to increase
because actually that terabyte
doesn't go very far because of the size
of the the os is quite big um
storage i would say would be my main
issue over the last year
um i'm constantly having to delete games
move games um
re-download them it's it's kind of a bit
frustrating whereas xbox is just like
yeah plugged in yeah storage and
the like no variation of xbox's smart
delivery at launch was rough for
playstation 5 i'm like no i don't
want the ps4 version of spider-man to
download on this game like one bucks
night
version it's like this is why is this so
hard
i mean it's good it's good that they
have updated all that stuff now it's
it's way easier to figure out which
version of a game you're playing the
other thing that i would like to see
change is um
we could talk about that we could talk
about like stuff we'll probably want to
see change later but it's like the um
the main screen like you don't have
themes anymore but you do have pictures
from each game and some of them they've
gone really overboard and it's like nice
music and stuff and something's just
like
playing nothing that's fine in terms of
other peripherals though i have the
headset and the camera and i love the
headset even though i have a tiny head
so it makes me look ridiculous the one
thing i'll say is that i don't use the
camera unnecessary cell phone look i
know like no one was gonna bring it up
lucy i wanted i want to get in front of
it because it does look really stupid on
my tiny tiny head however it does it is
really comfortable and it feels great
the one thing i will say is that i don't
use the camera for anything i forgot i
have one i did i also forgot i have one
until i found it when i was moving and i
was like oh [ __ ]
the peripherals on on the playstation
are
like also
a underappreciated goat is the charging
stand yeah that's the best like that
thing is really good like i love it i
i've had charging stands in the past and
they all eventually break or are crap in
some degree this is like an official
sony one and it's been a life saver you
can put two controllers i think on it or
three i can't remember it i think it's
two um i'm like i've not needed to plug
in my controller into the ps5 even once
in the entire year that i've owned it
that's the thing though i mean actually
if we're kind of on battery life i will
say the dual sense battery life
is not the best
it sucks i mean especially i mean i
think the gold standard for controller
battery life this this
i'm not even saying this gen because
switch was technically like last gen but
the the the pro controller on the switch
is
can just go forever whereas the dual
sensors like four or five hours for me
at this point depending on heavy usage
and so
i don't know
it could be it could be better i think i
think i was i was way warmer on dual
sense at the beginning of using it but
after using it for so long i still like
it as a controller but i think my heart
still belongs to the elite series too
downside with this uh deal sensor is
white controller boy
if you ever look at that controller
you're like i am the dirtiest as a white
controller with little symbols yeah it's
just like oh great
just the hand grime in this is unreal
before we move on to games one thing i
did want to ask is because there was a
lot of
people weren't sure about how the ps5
would look if it would fit into people's
entertainment centers because obviously
it's not just you know
a regular box it's um
i don't know it looks like a fancy opera
house
uh you know you what
everyone knows it looks like seto kaipa
from yu-gi-oh okay
yup it doesn't look
like the um
i'm getting sydney opera house meets the
um the one up in the sage up in
newcastle wait are you looking at it
vertical or horizontal i've got it i've
got it horizontal at the moment okay oh
okay um it's a bit more safe yeah so now
it does it does also look like a
building in dubai which you'd be like
why why have you done this
yeah i mean so it's obviously quite
different to a normal console are you
used to it are we liking the design now
or is it still kind of the i'll hide it
behind my tv so i don't have to look at
it
i can see yours mine's right there
proudly i'm not ashamed to be a gamer
and anyone who comes into this room will
see that i will put
any weird-looking device in public
display
because on the other side of that is my
xbox which i've actually packed away so
you can't see it wow big obelisk
uh just hanging out there i'm like yes
these do define my identity
so this is me i yeah this is me i do i
do like i i always like the playstation
5 the way it looks it's striking it's
different um and it's always it is like
a conversation starter even though no
one has been in this room other than me
in the lobby
like who's coming into your room and
this is the conversation it's a
conversation starter i have with myself
okay um
but it's nice ps5 you've got
thank you it's very strangely shaped
don't you think yes i do
um i do i do like it and i like the way
it i think i like it as a contrast to
the xbox it feels like it feels like a
nice kind of like offset of what
microsoft are doing very slick like we
want this to fade away kind of and it
very much does do that and it's also
when you look at you're like yeah it
looks powerful
and the playstation 5 is like
i am a gaming machine i'm a huge i am
here i am a gaming machine
and
i will challenge you with my blue eyes
white dragon if you're not careful
uh but i will say extremely worrying to
transport
without the original you don't keep the
original box you're kind of screwed yeah
that thing like you can't just pop that
into a normal box because it will like
you'll snap the top of it unless you
like remove the actual face plates um
it's not like that i was shamed into
throwing away my the boxes for myself
this is the problem you were you were
ashamed by people on twitter hating on
boxes i kept my box and i was like
oh do i have my box i found my box now i
feel comfortable at transporting that
bad boy to my new apartment i guess i
live here forever now yeah wait jordan
how are you feeling about the aesthetics
i mean half of my ps5 is hidden behind
my tv and the other half is hidden
behind the series x uh so i can't really
so that's that says everything
but chaotic have you got here yeah can
we get a picture i do not have like that
much room in
my room uh uh evan i'll send you a
picture of my setup so that the viewers
know what i'm talking about but it is
like one of those funny things where the
ps5 used to be the odd uh man out as the
only like white console i had and then i
upgraded my switch to the switch oled
and now my series x looks like
it doesn't belong i'm like damn i have
one black console i kind of wish i had a
series s so that they would all
match little match
yeah mine i don't know i literally got
an entertainment unit yesterday i'm
still not used to seeing it
it looks okay it looks okay i think i'm
used to it now but let's let's let's
talk about the games we've been going
for a while let's talk about the games
so we did an episode of console crew
slash gen next uh about the first year
the xbox series s and x and we kind of
all agreed that the exclusives
were pretty much the thing that let it
down it had some great ones but it
didn't necessarily have like huge huge
system sellers
uh big famous xbox um
first party and likes games that are
synonymous with xbox so playstation i
will say for my money came out of the
gate with way more bangers
um you know it is that scene of uh danny
devito saying so i started blasting yeah
like he's not a blasting that is how
sony came into this generation i would
say launching ps5 with demon souls miles
morales and astros playroom was like bug
snacks was bugs
it was a solid like first couple of
weeks
playstation um and then throughout the
year we've had things like return all
destruction all-stars uh remake
integrate for final fantasy vii
um
chicory is that console exclusive ration
clang ghost of sushma director's car
death stranding director's cut kane jet
the farshore fist
and
10 out of 10 games.com death loop so
it's been a pretty great yeah it has
it has been real good and like john said
demon souls to start with is like
that's a that's a banger to start with
not only like one of the most like
respected games in a long time a genre
starter even but also one of the most
sought after
remakes of all time like people were
desperate for that so for them to
announce it and then be like it's going
to be a playstation 5 launch title that
is like i think that's got to be like
one of the best launch titles ever yeah
the only way the only way microsoft
could have competed is if they had a
halo or if they had a big big big first
party title and they just didn't like
they had nothing which is um i mean they
had plenty of they they had yakuza like
a dragon which cannot be understated how
important that was because
that was that that that game was just
carrying microsoft
like
kasuga ichiban just with phil spencer on
his back like i'm going to carry you
through this bro
and and he did it he did it uh was
everyone's kind of standout ps5 gaming
experience from the year
i think for me it is probably demon
souls um and playing that uh
intensely for a day to review it
in one day still can't believe you did
that in a day that's very wild
but like uh i think miles morales was
also just
like jordan reviewed it and i i remember
just being fully absorbed by that game
like incredible game yeah
and also what like a nice move on uh
playstation's part to be like hey we're
gonna try to
do something this generation where it's
like it's a sequel to something we've
done but it's more like a seven to ten
hour almost like dlc expansion because
it's using virtually the same sort of
like assets and stuff like that from a
original game like this is smart you got
insomniac is just like
caring for playstation over the next
couple of years like
yeah and then obviously we're gonna have
another spider-man game and wolverine
and so they're also kind of building
momentum i think off of those releases i
think for my money i loved love demon
souls demon souls
just looked and felt so impressive i
remember just walking around that kind
of starting area and just trudging
through uh dredging through um
like swamp water or at least puddles
with um kind of pieces of green and i
was like oh my god look at the look at
like in the opposite of what happened
with spider-man i was like oh my god
look at the puddles guys look at the
puddles here are the puddles you wanted
everywhere yeah
um but i think in terms of things like
i really i really liked going back to
ghosts of tsushima and seeing how they'd
you know and to a lesser extent like
death stranding too is like taking ps4
games and bringing them up to ps5
but i think astros was like yes it's
kind of gimmick it's kind of gimmicky it
is to show off what the console can do
but i also think it was so full of heart
and just all of the little playstation
memories in it and all the little easter
eggs it was so cute i really enjoyed it
i really enjoyed it good game good game
underrated game unfortunately astros is
definitely like my first standout moment
on playstation 5 because like you said
it was very gimmicky but it was one of
those like going into the console i'm
like okay they've talked about the dual
sense
some people have like tried it already
i'm still not quite sure what this
controller is supposed to add to
gameplay and then astros playroom is
like this is what this controller can do
and i'm like i am sold a hundred percent
i love what this controller can do and
how it adds to the gaming experience
also like worth worth saying like they
did update some older games to be a
little more
beautiful beautiness
they update the beautiness on on like
god of war is one to jump back into and
i was like this is a nice
quickly
it loads and also it loads bloodborne
fractionally quicker and you know i'm
all about that life
are you you like bloodborne
no the one thing i'll say as well is
that um
oh i forgot it doesn't matter
i was just gonna say that like if astros
was your first
if astros was your first kind of
experience of like learning the dual
sense um that's amazing it felt even
better if you went and played i think
assassin's creed was a launch title came
out very very close to launch if you
played that where there was no no dual
sense stuff at all
and then you played astros you're like
oh this is what it could be like this is
a whole new world this is the future
uh well wow jordan thank you for teaming
me up with that segue but like the
future we already know that we're
getting uh horizon ghost by tokyo god of
war
um gt7 pragmata and
rumblings about stuff like final fantasy
16
there's also you know we're gonna be
getting final fantasy vii remake part
two
so even though there's not like uh
there's a few
amazing games in that lineup that i'm
excited to see more of um what are the
games what are the things that you're
excited about about the future of ps5 in
its second year
in its second year in its second year
what is blue point doing what is blue
point fresh freshly bought freshly
acquired
there has been rumors of circulating for
a long time about a metal gear solid
thing happening perhaps
i don't know anything they've been
working on it long enough that it's a
second year
imagine if imagine if they just remade
the first metal gear solid
i would explode
glad you said explode i don't know where
you were going to go with that
um
yeah i mean i think i think games wise
there's a lot to look forward to
um but also i think there's also
opportunities for change
um
you know quick resume is a feature that
we were talking about when we did the
xbox episode like quick resume is such a
game changer for chaotic people like me
um who'd like to kind of dip in and out
and stuff and the fact that there isn't
like any kind of quick resume type
functionality on the ps5 does kind of
suck
if they're trying to hide it where it's
like oh would you like to switch from
this game to this game i'm like this is
not actually switching from one of the
themes together
but also but also it was you know there
was that big problem with return where
the console would update overnight and
you would lose progress whereas like i
said i there was a power thing at my
there was a power outage at my place and
my xbox was like yo i got you we're fine
um i love the i in my mind i imagine it
as the xbox holding its breath
and then when you turn it back on that
next time it's like
i did it
they have i mean there have been nice
changes they kind of had a big update
where they changed things like that
command bar at the bottom and they sort
of streamlined i think friends could
still use a little work and i know they
tried to make player profiles more of a
thing but i can honestly say that i
never look at other people's profiles or
trophies or anything
um
it has been a year and i am still
holding the stupid playstation button to
try to turn off my console and i'm like
why why did you make this choice i i
would love it if they just added like or
maybe they do is there a setting where
you can change it where you hold the
button to turn it off instead of just
pressing it no it's rolling over there
isn't and that's what i was gonna say
how have they done this i do not
understand how we've reached a year into
this and they've
everyone learned
to hold the power button down or
playstation button down to bring up the
power off every single
console xbox does it too so it's like
just which does this point switch
i think the the
does it the 3ds does it
like everything does it and they went
the other way where they were like no if
you hold this down we're just going to
give you a menu and then you have to
why sony i'm sure you've got a reason
but i don't like it they might not have
a reason and it's sony they don't need
to explain themselves to the likes of us
the only thing i will say is that they
are clearly listening to feedback
because they made huge changes to things
like trophies because originally
trophies were horizontal and it was so
weird to try and scroll through a list
then they change it to be vertical
they've also added trophy tracking which
sometimes i get weirdly hyper fixated on
trophies i'm like i'm gonna platinum
this game and i'll just the fact that i
can pin stuff to the side and just like
knock out all the different trophies
that i want to get is really really good
so i'm intrigued to see
if they continue to improve
incrementally things like that i think
it's been an exceptionally strong year i
mean it's you can tell it's an
exceptionally strong year because
they're still so so difficult to buy
both playstation and xbox um
so
lads first year of ps5 um
let's let's get your overall overall
thoughts jordan i'll come to you
okay uh relating this to what i said at
the end of the xbox uh conversation
where i was like i kind of have an idea
of what xbox is doing but i have no idea
like where they're going with this with
playstation i have like an idea based on
their first year where they're going
with this they both sold me the ticket
and convinced me to actually get on the
plane to go where they want to go where
i'm like okay they have
sequels to a lot of their traditional
games like uh
god of war horizon spider-man stuff like
that but they also have these more
experimental things or like oh we're
gonna be like the big budget movie
people still like xbox can have its
whole subscription thing there are the
netflix that you watch and binge every
day where you're going to the movies but
we're going to have a wider diversity of
movies both in terms of like not just
white straight male main characters
because we're getting things like death
loop and miles morales and chicory where
it's like a wider variety of
protagonists fraternal cana bridge of
spirits but also just like games that i
would not have ever expected playstation
to have before
games like returnal and kano where i'm
like oh these are really cool and
they're almost like
big budget indie films if for lack of a
better term i'm like and i like this
direction that playstation has
established like we're still doing the
thing that we love doing but we're also
going to take you on this journey to
explore types of quote unquote film
video games that you did not get on ps4
so like i i i love this first year and i
cannot wait to see what they have in
store for year two yeah i i mean like
just like with the the xbox like i'm i i
love these consoles like i love the
playstation 5 and i'm having such a good
time playing games on it and sony as a
company is very exciting for everything
that jordan mentioned there i think the
the potential that they also have
they're clearly
they're making big reaches and they're
making some they're making us aware of
the fact that they know some of the
things that we want and they started
doing that when they
you know um
showed off final fantasy 7 remake like
they're starting to dip into the like
this is a you know fantasy uh
announcement fantasy project vibe um
kind of uh thing with that and then
demon souls and
i think whether or not it happens i'm
now more inclined to believe that sony
will do something crazy like announce
that they have acquired male gear solid
or they have
built built built some sort of
relationship where they can make the
next one or something like as wild as
we're bringing siphon filter back or
where you know we're doing xyz thing
like it could be anything but like
sony is at a place right now where it
feels like they could make those big big
jumps or big big like uh
kind of uh high promotion
or kind of like high buzz plays and that
is incredibly exciting i think the
future of playstation is is
kind of
unknowable because of that and that's
exciting you can never tell what sony's
going to do like we never expected a
wolverine game and that's a there it is
like they've done it and they've i'm
excited for it
yeah exactly we never we never expected
return we never expected yeah you know a
lot of the games that are have defined
the first year and you know we know some
of the things coming like horizon and
from this point on i feel like they
could make some
massive swings and that's exciting
hell yeah well we'll always have all the
latest um that was the first year of ps5
we also have a companion video where we
talk about kind of the first year of the
xbox series s and x um it's up on the
channel for more uh make sure to like
this video and subscribe to gamespot i'm
on twitter at least james games jordan
you can find me on twitter at jmremay
and tam
uh you'll find me at tomorrow h
thank you so much for watching catch you
next time
bye
[Music]
you